I'm 17 it's February 1991 I have no
parents at this point and a girl I've
been seeing briefly in high school has
now moved to Indianapolis and I have no
one to tell me no or that I can't go or
anything so I decide I'm gonna ride a
greyhound by myself from Maryland to
Indianapolis how's that so [ __ ] well
I did this to I'll tell you half all
right good cuz this is the [ __ ] you'll
do for you know hormones and
testosterone make you do so I get on
this Greyhound in Frederick Maryland I
have a buddy driving me out there
dropped me off get on the Greyhound and
then we're gone you know it's supposed
to be oh no I think was supposed to be
like an 11 hour 12-hour ride on a
greyhound one-way right and we get on
and we hit our first stops Wheeling West
Virginia and people are throwing [ __ ] at
the bus and everything like what the
[ __ ] is going on and that guy's like
we're on strike and I'm like what the
scabs driving us right now this
[ __ ] crawls to pick a lot they
are throwing like lettuce and cabbage
and like old school to throwing [ __ ] at
the [ __ ] we're like what the [ __ ] are
you talking about so now he's scared
were delayed there it's supposed again
supposed to be I think it like a 12-hour
ride or something the next stop is gonna
be Pittsburgh we get into Pittsburgh
there they are not having the Greyhound
strike at Pittsburgh miss dude you're
still driving us you know so it takes it
takes like 18 or 19 hours ultimately to
get there
all these [ __ ] up so I get there her mom
really liked me the mom's always like
because I think the moms felt sorry for
me and the dads were just looking at me
like this is you know a walking erection
so now I'm in in Indiana
again it's February it's I'm 17 I turn
18 in March it's [ __ ] freezing even
more there it's cold as [ __ ] and her dad
is going to work and coming home and
he's home now and it's late and she and
I are on the couch and we're making out
but we're fully clothed but I mean we're
have
sex in our clothes you know what I mean
like and we don't realize that the TV
has gone to static remember back in the
day when TV's will go to static in the
morning sure we don't even pay any mind
to it and I'm on top of this girl and
I've got my head like you know down in
here and her neck and kissing and
talking to her and [ __ ] and then all I
hit all of a sudden I hear get your ass
in your room and I'm like boom and I
know it's her dad and I know he is
standing right the [ __ ] here and I don't
know what to do I have no idea what to
do I'm I'm stuck I'm in Indiana I can't
get up I'll go home I'm 17 I you know
what I mean I can't be like I'm just
gonna show myself out and go home I'm
stuck in their house for one more day
and night and she of course is their dad
she just I mean she slid out under me
gave me [ __ ] nose burn you know I be
a pearl and I don't know what to do dude
and I [ __ ] roll over and I just go
and I play I lay there like I'm sleeping
I mean he just watch me humping dry
humping he stands there I can hear him
breathing
he doesn't say anything but I don't [ __ ]
I'm like I'm winning this one and I mean
you know when you fake sleep in your
eyes move yeah my eyes didn't [ __ ]
move I was dead I had my mouth open and
that was I was like wait I don't
understand though so he saw you and then
you just yeah I did that it was like
humping humming humming rolled over and
I did she stood out front and he stood
there and literally I just rolled over
and went and played sleep I don't know
the villas so scared I was like is he
gonna beat a sleeping child I don't know
but I could hear him standing right here
and I was like I'm not but and he walked
away for a while he stood there and then
he [ __ ] walked away and then I was
like and what happened I didn't realize
was he had come down the hallway it was
one of those houses where you could make
a right into the kitchen and then it
kept going through the dining room and
circled into the living room so he had
come
to get a drink insult and circled around
like what the [ __ ] and boom
so in the morning he's got to go to work
and I got to see him and I mean I don't
I literally don't feel good I physically
do not feel I feel ill I tell her mom
he's obviously gone back there and told
the mom he went back and yelled at his
daughter and he's got to go to work so I
tell them what the moms like would you
let you see the baby would you like some
breakfast and I'm like I don't really
feel good she said why don't you go lay
down in my son's room he's gone I was
like okay so I go in there I'm thinking
you know I'm in here doors shut cuz I'm
sleeping on there yeah yeah I know like
I'm exposed to everything but in here
I'm safe he'll leave for work and then
that'll be the end of it after the old
room one more night when he comes home
and this [ __ ] throws the doram
goes my wife said you're not feeling
good and I was just like yeah he goes he
shuts the door that's it that's it
no I was like [ __ ] this guy's gonna kill
me tonight when he comes home he's gonna
[ __ ] he's gonna be stewing about this
all day all day and come home and kill
me and that [ __ ] got snowed in
at work that night there was a man he
had to stay at it like the construction
team I saw he was pissed but I was like
because the morning I was up and out of
my gray out I was gone he wasn't see me
at all dude so I head back on this
ground I'm so excited I'm excited to get
on this greyhound because I'd rather do
that didn't face her dad oh yeah and I
remember the whole way out to was this
redneck named Vern it said I'll never
forget this guy had the biggest buck
teeth and there was some kind of some
[ __ ] went down in the back of the bus
people fighting or whatever you know and
uh
you know I said they're throwing [ __ ] at
the bus and stuff it's due to pack the
lunch he just looked at me I'll never
this line sticks with me still he just
looks because I'm eating my sandwich and
he just sat there next to be eating his
[ __ ] sandwich I get back to Maryland
and her dad calls and this dude is
checking on me and I'm telling you he
couldn't have been nicer and I was like
it just must have been look this guy's
the [ __ ] out of here I never need to see
him again you know and never nothin ever
happen anyway he called I called her and
he got on the phone
and he was so [ __ ] nice he's like how
you feeling feeling better so years
later I go to a party they have I'm I'm
visiting I'm in town I go to a big party
they have and her brother comes over and
her dad and I are talking and I'm saying
this is I mean God years and years later
twelve fifteen years later and her
brother comes over and goes remember
that time my dad caught you dry humping
my sister in the living room for her
dad's talking to me and I go dad looks
at me cuz been meaning to talk to you
about that and I was like oh [ __ ] and I
just [ __ ] got the [ __ ] out we're good
we ain't talking about that okay yeah
I'll never do greyhound again no that
was those the worst at your level right
now would you get on a [ __ ] greyhound
just to go anywhere anywhere I wouldn't
get on a greyhound out of Hollywood from
here yeah dude I haven't done it it's
one of the worst experiences of my life
okay I was in I was a freshman in
college it's like you're saying what
you'd do for your hormones girl I'm
seeing
she's I'm she's good she's in Charleston
and I'm a freshman who doesn't know I
look up how far Hickory North Carolina
is to Charleston and it's like five and
a half hours I was like it's not that
bad I buy my bus ticket for like a
hundred bucks or whatever it is I get on
that bus and I don't realize because I'm
too naive that there are multiple stops
along the way it takes 11 and Louisville
dude we go at one point we go to [ __ ]
it's from you know North Carolina so we
go to a military base so we go off the
route and we drive [ __ ] 40 miles this
way to pick up one guy at the military
base then you go all the way back stop
it all I was like I had no idea some but
involvement on the bus
so I was gonna say yeah people [ __ ] on
it I mean knock on his melanin and then
you just see like it was like it was so
bad that I remember when I got there I
was trying to think if there's an
alternative way to get back and there
wasn't but all I did for the less than
48 hours that I was gonna see cuz I had
to get back for was just think about the
misery of having to ride back it was
like the worst cuz the whole time I was
there as I can't believe Eddie get on
this [ __ ] bus again it was depressing
it was such a bad no like that
experience was my first and last
distance bus ride they whatever or still
worse way to go so I walk over and I'm
like dude are you Chuck D he's like I am
I go what the [ __ ] are you doing in a
gray house day he says please don't tell
other people he doesn't want people
coming up to him and [ __ ] I'm like I
won't tell anybody and then we got on
that bus and like that's Chuck D in the
back there yeah and they all he was on
the bus he was on the [ __ ] bus today